من الله
نشراتنا الاخباريه من قناه العربي
وهذا حدث
كارثه
وفي خطر عاجل منذ قليل اضربوهم في الليل
والنهار اسد مراسل العربيه ان خمسه
انفجارات
في العراق
العربي واسماء للعالم العربي
اليوم بينما بلادنا تعيش هذا التحول
العظيم تحت قياده خادم الحرمين الشريفين
الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز
وسمو ولي عهده رئيس مجلس الوزراء الامير
محمد بن سلمان
فان العربيه تضاعف الجهود كي تكون بقدر
التحديات الجديده وكى تكون الوسيله
الاعلاميه الاكثر قدره ومصداقيه في
تعبيرها عن القفز التنمويه الهائله وعن
الدور السياسي الرائد المحوري الذي تلعبه
المملكه العربيه السعوديه في المنطقه
والعالم
حاله الطوارئ وهذا رغم التعبئه تخلى
الرئيس التونسي زين العابدين بن علي عن
السلطه ثلاثه قتلى ومئات الاصابات
اشتباكاته يحاسبه الذين اجرموا في حق
الشباب المتظاهرين
قبل الانتاج بواحد مليون برميل الاداه
الاستثمانيه الاهم من المملكه في المرحله
المقبله الدولار معظمها مصممه في قطاع
النفط
التوقعات
اصلاح الليل
دراسي
عربيه ثمن
قتل سبعه اشخاص بينهما عدد من العاملين في
قناه العربيه في انفجار سياره كل انسان
علاقه
بلحظه الموت
في يوم من الايام
راحتانو
العربيه
[موسيقى]
لشبكه العربيه احدث غرفه
عربي مهم جدا
وقناه يتابعونها السعوديين والعرب بشكل
مكثف
ونعتقد انها رسالتنا سوف تصل للسعوديين
والعالم العربي
واذا تاملنا حقيقه ما فعلته العربيه خلال
عشرين عاما نرى كيف
رسخت قيم الصحافه الحقيقيه
تبنت الموضوعيه ولم تخلط بين الراي والخبر
سعت الى المصداقيه بكل الطرق حتى لو اغضبت
البعض
كان من السهل عليها ان تحرك الغرائز
او ان تتلاعب بعواطف الناس كسبا
للجماهيريه ولكنها لم تفعل
المهنيه كانت وجهتها الاساسيه التي لم تحد
عنها منذ عشرين عاما وحتى هذا اليوم
كان ذلك تحديا كبيرا نجحت فيه رغم العوائق
والصعوبات
[موسيقى]